[Music]
say goodbye to cute funny and absolutely
gorgeous Disney characters you know and
love get ready because some of these
characters will give you serious
nightmares you'll never be able to look
at Snow White the same way again if you
haven't yet make sure you subscribe to
the thing to never miss another Disney
video again give this video a thumbs up
because today we're checking out ten
Disney characters reimagined as monsters
Princess Jasmine let's start with the
princess who's so gorgeous she had an
influence on the early sketches of the
main male character of the movie they
thought Aladdin's original look was far
too scruffy for such a beautiful
princess well if Jasmine's real looks
were anything like the illustration
we're about to show you we're pretty
sure the whole movie would have a very
different setting you can thank the
deviantART users zombie roses for this
awesome illustration Princess Jasmine is
now a zombie we told you this script
would give you nightmares we can imagine
the plot - Aladdin would have to change
a whole lot if the characters became
actual zombies let's not forget that
Jasmine isn't even the main character in
the story and yet she still managed to
steal the spotlight we bet that with
this zombie look Jasmine might as well
become the main focus of Aladdin's story
from what it looks like the zombie
Jasmine seems to only have one arm and
she's sporting a bit of a different look
from the original Princess Jasmine did
you know that in the Arabian Nights
which is the original story of Aladdin
Princess Jasmine is actually named bad
drool the door that name seems to be
quite fitting for the zombie looking
Princess Jasmine
Princess Tiana the next design was
created by the very talented Slovakian
painter who goes by the name of Gabby
she's quite known for creating stunning
zombie painting and she did a really
good job with one of our favorite Disney
Princesses Princess Tiana knows that
working hard can make her dreams come
true she doesn't let things stand in her
way and she's incredibly bold and wise
Tiana is a perfect example of a
progressive Disney Princess in fact she
doesn't even become a princess until the
end of the movie and we have yet to see
how her story would unfold now that she
has her princess status but what we can
show you is what Princess Tiana would
look like as a monster yes one of the
most underrated Disney Princesses is now
zombified
you you might want to close your eyes
because this one is just downright scary
check out that piece of frog leg in her
mouth we all know how dedicated and
hard-working Tiana is when it comes to
her dreams with that in mind it makes us
think she could still portray her story
even if she'd be zombified we just feel
bad for that poor frog do you think this
was her prince or just a random animal
Chicken Little
now here's a character we haven't talked
much about on this channel
do you remember Chicken Little the teeny
tiny chicken was convinced the sky was
falling and everyone thought he was just
crying wolf even though he was right
it's hard to imagine his goofy character
could resemble anything other than a
chicken but the team behind freaking
News reimagined him into a very
impressive looking monster we love the
dark cloak he's wearing and he looks
like he wants to get revenge on anyone
who laughed at him before did you know
that Chicken Little was the second fully
computer-generated movie and the first
movie using Disney's digital 3d
animation tools apart from the film
called dinosaur all previous Disney
movies had been drawn by hands the movie
was Disney's chance to show what the
company can do using animation and they
certainly did their job after Chicken
Little only The Princess and the Frog
and Winnie the Pooh still followed the
old hand-drawn tradition we can't
imagine the skill that's needed to
hand-draw this version of Chicken Little
and turn it into a Disney movie but
we're very interested in how it would
all turn out a zombie version of chicken
littles sounds like a good idea
Belle let's go back to the world of
Disney Princesses because we found one
French princess who is rock in the
monster look and we wanted to show you
what she looks like the world of
illustration really has no limits even
though Belle is too sweet too kind and a
way too compassionate to look like a
monster this picture did the monster
Belle justice this design belongs to the
Slovakian illustrator called Gabby who
also painted the amazing Princess Tiana
we showed you earlier
well the zombie version of Belle looks
like it's been through some hard times
she looks like she needs a few good
hours of sleep to cover those red eyes
can you imagine this version of Belle
walking down the streets of her village
and singing Bonjour to everyone do you
think anyone would even answer her back
speaking of monsters and Beauty and the
Beast did you know that the Beast is
made of seven different animals they
include a lion a buffalo a gorilla a
human a wild boar a bear
- wolf and yet those combinations will
never look as scary as the monster
version of Belle can you imagine this
spell ever pairing up with the Beast now
get ready because the next illustration
might just ruin your childhood opinions
of the beloved lilo and stitch stitch
lilo and stitch was one of the first
Disney movies to feature realistic body
types on their main female characters
lilo was shown as a very real character
who sometimes a brat but she also
struggles with fitting in stitch was
also an extraordinary character while
other Disney Princesses and other female
characters tend to have a cute and funny
sidekick stitch had to be taught how to
be good and kind the movie teaches us
about the importance of family love and
bond after all ohana means family and
family means that nobody gets left
behind or forgotten but would that quote
still apply if stitches looks would
drastically change this fantastic design
belongs to an incredible artist
Alberto Montoya who managed to zombify
quite a few of your favorite Disney
characters stitch looks like he's been
through some serious hardships what do
you think is this what stitch would look
like if he'd never been taught the
importance of kindness did you notice
that when stitch got adopted and nany
was handed the adoption papers the text
was an acknowledgement of the hard work
the lilo and Stitch team put in to make
this movie it seems like the creative
team behind the movie worked hard to
create this Disney classic Mickey Mouse
you know we can't talk about Disney
characters without mentioning the one
and only Mickey Mouse Mickey Mouse's
first appearance was in Steamboat Willie
in 1928 which makes him pretty old this
Mouse character is one of the most
recognizable faces in the world did you
know that he even beats Santa Claus
everyone knows Mickey Mouse but would
people still know him if he transformed
into a monster this design belongs to a
deviantART user called dry spirit who
did a fantastic job with making Mickey
just a bit crazier than usual with his
big eyes sharp teeth long tongue and a
stance that's up to no good this version
of Mickey takes the friendly Mouse
character to the next level did you know
that Mickey Mouse's story starts with a
rabbit called Oswald the Lucky Rabbit
who was sold to Universal and became
popular long story short it turned out
that Universal retained all rights to
the Oswald character and Walt Disney was
back to square one the
inspired him to create a brand new
character he calls Mickey Mouse and the
rest is history
well we're quite glad that his original
Mickey Mouse didn't look anything like a
zombie his looks are so iconic that many
Disney fans love to play the Hidden
Mickey game where they try to find the
Mickey Mouse shape and other disney
movies our next character is part of the
world that's full of Mickey Mouse Easter
eggs
Ariel well it looks like Ariel no longer
wishes she could be part of this world
after all the 16 year old princess is
known for her stubbornness and not
taking no for an answer her personality
makes her instantly loveable although
her free spirit does bring quite a lot
of anxiety out of her friends flounder
and Sebastian her original looks were
based on the one and only Alyssa Milano
who joked that she does have red hair
and wears a clamshell bra at home who do
you think this zombie Ariel was inspired
by the stunning illustration belongs to
a deviantART user Nicola Chan and it
shows an entirely different side to the
Little Mermaid we know and love she
looks like she's been eaten by something
that was also able to completely remove
her eyes and it's not a beautiful sight
we told you that the Little Mermaid has
quite a few of Mickey Mouse sightings in
the movie and we weren't lying you can
spot Mickey as well as Goofy and Donald
Duck at the beginning of the film as
well as in a few hand-drawn bubbles do
you think Disney would ever create the
Little Mermaid remake with zombie
characters if that ever happens it's
safe to say that this will no longer be
a movie suitable for children Popeye
he's strong to the finish because he
eats his spinach
he's Popeye the sailorman we haven't
discussed Popeye much on this channel
but the super-strong spinach loving
Sailor man deserves a mention Popeye
dates back to 1919 and the character was
inspired by a real person named Frank
rocky Fiegel whose habits are quite
similar to the cartoon version of Popeye
did you know that for about a decade
since the launch of the cartoon there
has been a 33 percent increase in
children eating spinach now that's an
impressive accomplishment
Popeyes looks aren't necessarily
appealing but they do portray a typical
sailor man but this artist who goes by
the name of Andre de Freitas turns South
eye into a pretty convincing zombie it
looks like eating spinach doesn't really
help with your immune system when you
forget to brush your teeth the image
does bring a new story for Popeye
and we'd love to see the pipe smoking
character in a terrifying cartoon we bet
the percentage of children who eat
spinach would drop if Popeye looks like
a zombie
did you know Popeye has his own theme
park in Malta where the famous actor
Robin Williams filmed the live-action
film adaptation of the popular cartoon
the theme park is still active and open
for business and we know one disney
princess who probably loves theme parks
rapunzel the 18 year old happy-go-lucky
Disney Princess is one of our favorites
she's brave sometimes naive and she goes
after what her heart wants her sweet
charming looks only add to her cheerful
character but can you imagine what
Rapunzel would look like if she became a
monster
this illustration belongs to a
deviantART user called clock tower man
who did an amazing version of bringing
out the not so gorgeous side of this
Disney Princess this Rapunzel looks like
she's had enough of her adoptive
mother's behavior and will ignore the
fact that she's holding just a part of
her animal sidekick task ow we can't
even imagine what she did to her
significant other who charmed us with
his smoldering looks and his dry sense
of humor the illustrator did an amazing
job in bringing out a completely
different side to our favorite Disney
Princess did you know that Rapunzel's
hair is 70 feet long and it holds around
a hundred thousand strands speaking of
tangles a fan theory states that Mother
Gothel could play another Disney
character in a movie that was released
in 1937 seventy three years before
tangled debut can you guess which movie
were talking about it involves apples
and seven tiny humans with names that
reflect their personalities Snow White
and last but not least it's the Disney
princess that started off the whole
disneymania Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs was first released in 1937 and
the iconic classic set is standard for
all future Disney movies Snow White is
one of the youngest Disney Princesses at
just 14 years old she's showing
incredible kindness and compassion
toward everyone including animals and
it's why we love her but what her kind
character change if she looks like this
deviantART artist sue Menna
reimagined Snow White as a monster and
this picture is terrifying we do want to
highlight how amazing it is to see Snow
White in a completely different light
it's hilarious that the
zombie version of snow white still looks
kind of cute with the bow in her hair
and her face shape the original story of
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs is a bit
more gruesome than you think it turns
out that the Queen asked a hunter to
bring back Snow White's lungs and liver
which means this version of the Disney
Princess might make a bit more sense
however we do still prefer the snow
white with a unique voice and her seven
extraordinary pals that are there to
back her up looking for more videos like
this one don't forget to check out 20
cartoon characters reimagined in 3d
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
and give this video a thumbs up if you
love Disney see you next time
[Music]